I can see the world though in a in the
future where I'm not missing out on
those opportunities so that's my vision
for this world my vision is to be able
to have incidental learning experiences
the point is and the key is access for
everyone here today
so this is the Deaf constructor who's in
our College of Liberal Arts he teaching
psychology he's teaching a course here
on the neurobiology of schizophrenia and
what we'll do during the question
session at the end of the talk I would
ask that you ask your questions through
your device so that what happened is in
the question mode it will actually show
who is asking the question and show a
transcript of your question on the
screen
it learned a lot about the classroom
experience and the learning experiment
in my college photolyze is very
important as well
do you have studies that show changes
that technology can promote in terms of
the death and the urine students talking
to each other or communicating with each
other
if you mean communicating through
technology it hasn't been done yet
I get wrote about it in a chapter that
just went to prep one of the issues for
deaf kids even the ones who are now
using spoken language an implant is that
in elementary school there aren't too
many issues except that the kids deaf
kids who have the best hearing and
speech are the ones who are most
accepted by the hearing kids